- [Interviewer] All right Janeth,
Janeth where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally.
- [Janeth] I grew up in South central.
Yeah. And the real
hard core South Central, gang affiliated.
And I started gang when
I was like 13 years old.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
With your parents?
- My stepdad raped me.
Yeah. Yeah.
My stepdad raped me and my
mom, my mom was still with him
for the, till the last day he died.
Which was last year.
He raped me and my sister.
So when that happened, I
took it upon myself to, to
to think that, that I was just
like, I used to tell my mom
my step dad used to do something.
She never believed me or my sister.
So my sister left one day,
my, my oldest s, my, one of my
my sisters, he was rapping too.
So when he, what happened
was that, and the
while this was happening.
My sister left me and she,
she left with my auntie
and left me in the
house, with the problem.
So that kind of fucked me
up, you know, even worse
because now she's out of
the picture, being raped.
And now it's me.
So now, now I'm getting more
often than I was getting it now
for my stepdad.
And it was, it was, it was
fucked up. It was really bad.
- [Interviewer] Did this
go on for a long time?
- Oh yeah.
That's happened when I was seven years old
like six, seven, and I'm, I'm what 40 now.
But he just died last year.
So this opportunity, like, I was like
this happened six, like three years, seven
like for two years a year,
I said a year, two years.
Yeah. Yeah.
He raped me and stuff.
And me and my sister
and I remember being
this older, being like,
when I was like 17 and she
was like eight, like 19
we told my, our mom and
she didn't believe us.
She said, you guys are crazy.
You guys use drugs.
We were like, at that
age, mom, come on now,
we don't.
So my stepdad passed
away last year and I don't have religion.
I don't, I don't have I'm out
here in the street by myself.
You know, I go to
I went to prison, did 7 years upstate,
Chowchilla, and I'm just
I just know nothing, but
the hardcore live out there
the dangerous life, gangs, drugs, guns
and game bangers, you know, fighting.
And, you know, I just, I mean, I mean
I have a long face shooting for.
- [Interviewer] What
were you in prison for?
- For stabbing somebody
with a kitchen knife.
- [Interviewer] Stabbing
someone with a kitchen knife?
- Yeah, My baby daddy,
the father of my child.
- [Interviewer] Oh your.
- Yes, I did.
I'm seven years.
Upstate.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] And hmm
prostitution started
for you, at what age?
- I was like 13, 14, 14?
Yes. When I ran away from my house.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember your first time?
Yes. sunset Hollywood, right there.
My first ticket too.
- [Interviewer] Your ticket too?
Trust, I think they call it.
Tr, no not trespassing.
I forgot there is that one.
- [Interviewer] Hooker?
Yeah that one yes.
And they let me go the first time.
But the second time it was like
I went to jail to twin towers.
This was, this was when
twin tower was open.
So I'm like, way, way, way, way.
We talked about way back,
to where I could, I could, I
could the, the, the, you know
the lawsuit that they
got going on right now
and stuff about the
women that whoever goes
to jail in 2000, whatever,
I qualify for that.
So, yeah, I used to go to train tower
and stuff for a prostitution and stuff.
And you know, when they all
had a bad experience to where
like my friends were in the street
or their long beach and
wild man, it was just bad.
She, I guess she knew, what she was.
She, she just never listened.
She didn't listen.
She didn't.
I told her exactly what to do
but she went the wrong
way and she got killed.
Yeah. She got killed right there.
And then she got, when
she got raped at first.
And then they killed her.
Yes. Yes.
Hispanic people.
Yes. The stuff that I didn't
know that she was doing
you know what I mean?
Because before I used to be
like, Oh, everybody's my friend.
Now. I want to help everybody.
I wanted to help everybody, everybody.
And it's not, it's like, you
cannot help them know somebody.
They don't want to help yourself.
You know?
So I just got of jail again two years ago
and they gave me two years.
I did a year and due to COVID-19 they
gave me five months early kick-out
and I came home and I lost all of my kids.
I lost my house.
I lost everything.
I'm in the streets right now.
Yep. I'm just right now.
I'm in the streets.
- [Interviewer] So your homeless?
- Yes, I'm homeless.
Oh yeah, I'm homeless.
I sleep, I sleep in my car.
So my friends that I know,
you know what I mean?
They let me shower.
Sometimes they let me in
the house, I mean, you know,
sometimes I go without showering I mean.
I mean, sometimes the police will be over.
They'll be like, you're homeless?
I'm like, I'm homeless.
He's like, no, you're not homeless.
You don't look like your homeless.
I'm like, Oh my God
really? Like, I am homeless.
It's like, yes, I'm homeless.
What does homeless look like?
You know?
So you know that yesterday
was Thanksgiving.
It was familiar but
just like any other day.
Any other day.
Yup. Cause I don't
I don't have, I lost my
son to his gang member too.
He's doing 50 to life.
So, you know, it's kind
of hard when you, when I
sometimes I say I want to change
but then it's like for what?
And he's like, I waited out, you know
but I think I like, that's
the only thing I know,
is this lifestyle.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted to it?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you
using drugs as well?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What do you use?
- Meth
- [Interviewer] Meth. It helps you do this
kind of work, right?
- Yeah. It numbs my pain.
- [Interviewer] Do you
talk to your family at all?
Not at all?
- I don't.
- [Interviewer] And where are your kids?
- In the system?
Social services.
Yeah. They took them away
from because i had nobody
to put them, when the
police pulled me over
You know what I mean?
So I was doing so so good.
I asked myself, I told God, like
why would you let all this happen
to me when I was just
doing fine with my kids?
Like, cause I do want to change.
I do.
But it's like, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Do you
get depressed sometimes?
- Oh yeah.
I, yes, that, that triggers
the trigger in them.
I mean, I don't have no support.
I mean, you know how you
always have somebody to
push you, like, come on, come on, come on.
Like somebody, you
know, I don't have that.
You know what I mean?
I mean, all the people
that I'm around with
they do the same shit I do.
So it's like, I mean, why would they care
for me when they lost their kids already?
So it's like, you know
the streets is rough out there right now.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What else,
what helps you survive there?
You tell yourself, this
is just something you
need to do just to pay the bills or
- It builds.
Yeah. Yes.
- [Interviewer] But he'd
being molested as a kid.
Did that kind of lead you down this path?
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] You feel like
maybe if that hadn't happened
- Well maybe my mom would pay more
attention to us, you know?
So.
I feel that all my family discombobulated
because they always talk about
me, being drugs and gangs,
in prison and you know, just,
just things that, you know
- [Interviewer] What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- If I would've made better
choices, I wouldn't be where I'm
at right now,
because I can't blame a lot of people
for what I do.
It's me.
And I'm not gonna, I see.
Like I see like, like people
that are in the streets always
got something to blame like,
Oh, cause I'm like this
because they know.
It's cause it's cause it's
you, you know what I mean?
Like I joined the gang when I was 13.
So cause I thought the
world was going to end,
you know? So
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- [Janeth] In love?
Yeah, like two times, but I don't know.
Like I don't, I don't really care.
Like when I'm on the
street, I'm so more like to
do vicious stuff than to be with sexually.
You know what I mean?
Cause I'm like aggressive.
Like, like though I don't like
nobody telling me what to do.
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like I have
to go hard, hard on people
you know what I mean?
And I don't care if I scare them.
I don't care if I fight.
I like to, I just fought
somebody two days ago.
I mean, that's just my thing.
That's I blackout when I, you
know, I take segments too.
So I don't know.
I'm just, I don't know.
It's got to do with being in the streets
and then my son, my mom
I see a lot of stuff that builds
when my sister passed away.
And then you got my other
home boy from my neighborhood,
That passed the, got killed.
They went inside, look
into his RV, shot him.
So he's like, man, it's
just a lot of stuff.
You know?
I don't want to end up like
like these people like
lost, lost like a lost sole.
So I don't, I don't want
to end up like that.
- [Interviewer] What's
your biggest regret.
- Being in a gang.
- [Interviewer] Gang?
- Yeah. It's not worth it.
Yeah. Cause when you're a gang member.
You, you, you, you, feel, you,
that's what your known for.
You know what I mean?
Like police pull me over.
If I'm, if I'm with you, coming
for a restaurant eating,
police pull me over.
They going to see my
tattoo, and say oh yeah
What, what are you, what is
this guy doing with this girl?
Like this?
You know, like the judges
us, you know the book, they
they judge the book by its cover.
You know, my family is like that.
You know, that's why my family
is always discombobulated.
Cause they always, always
nothing nice to say
to tell me it was always bad.
It's always bad.
So I just said, fuck my family too.
You know, it'd been three years.
From the day I got arrested
in November of last year.
I haven't talked to my family
for three fucking years.
And when I got arrested
I called my mom after three years, she
this is the first the thing
she told me, why you calling?
Because you in jail? You need me?
Now you need me?
Huh?
She said, Oh man, cause
they're Hispanic. Oh, wow.
And then, and I was like,
Oh man, I was so mad
Mad.
They say, they're not
going to pick up my kids.
They left my kids in the system.
So I mean, you know, I do my side.
I do everything my own.
I asked my homeboys, my friends,
you know, they be looking
out for me.
So sometimes I would go to
sleep without eating, you know?
Cause I don't have money to eat
- [Interviewer] Street
life is ruthless isn't it?
- It is. That's why I tell people.
You go home.
If you have home, go home
like go home to your mom,
go home to your kids.
Like don't fuck that up.
You know what I mean?
Like, cause it's not worth it.
Like don't fuck it up.
Be smart.
You know?
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- Having baby, my last one, C-section.
- [Interviewer] And
what was the worst time?
- Knowing that my son is doing 50 to life.
- [Interviewer] If you
could change something
about your life, your childhood,
what would you change?
- [Janeth] To become a
better mother for my kids.
I feel worthless sometimes
but I don't let nobody know that.
Cause I'm in the street.
- [Interviewer] All right, Janeth.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- [Janeth] Thank you.